ah yes Return of the Jedi what can one
say about Return of the Jedi well it's
the third one yeah okay full disclosure
I love this movie
a lot of people do for me it's a
childhood classic but a lot of fans and
critics alike have pointed out its flaws
of it ears and honestly kind of have a
point the plan to bust Han out of
Jabba's palace makes zero sense the
greatest bounty hunter in the galaxy
goes out like Wiley coyote the second
Death Star is redundant and even then I
don't know how the Empire Falls so
quickly Lando gets off completely
scot-free Leia's made out to be the
rebellions last hope but all she does is
sit around and try on the Ewoks latest
fall fashion line up and hung well she's
just look at him and then there's the
Ewoks Jedi had was a bunch of Muppets I
think the biggest problem though is that
it never feels like the characters
really sacrifice anything yeah boohoo
Vader dies but he was the bad guy who
cares all the good guys were untouched
and all of this came after the most
shocking film in the series The Empire
Strikes Back
there the tone was darker the stakes
were higher and it seemed like anyone or
any appendage could be on the chopping
block so effective was that movie that
the new Disney trilogy seems desperate
to call back to it again and again but
something about it in the trilogy set 30
years later just isn't resonating with
some people and I got me thinking maybe
Return of the Jedi set the happy
redundancy meter a little too high in
force awakens many people didn't want to
see a star killer planet unless Jedi a
lot of people didn't want to see Luke
Skywalker die han dealing with regret
didn't seem satisfying years later and
only now does Leia have to deal with
true loss the loss of her brother
husband and son what happened to the
happy fairytale ending fair enough
but what of these things particularly
catastrophic events like Luke's death
the construction of a Starkiller base
and embittered Han and embattled Leia
happened earlier
is it possible to craft a third film in
the trilogy morte
only consistent with Empire Strikes Back
more importantly is it possible to craft
a script that would make more sense you
know maybe solve all the little plot
holes and tie up loose ends well that's
the experiment today so grab some
popcorn cuz this is gonna be a long one
and just to make it extra harder I'm
gonna try to skip some of the easy
answers so no killing Han no planet full
of wookies we all know these were early
ideas in the process I'm hoping to stick
too much of Lucas's original intent for
better or worse nature vs. technology a
superior force outwitted by the least
likely of creatures and they're always
being another way
so let's lay the film's problems all on
the table there we go these are the
biggest issues with the movie now if
there's only one thing that all Star
Wars fans can agree on is that they
don't agree on anything so maybe some
things on the list don't bug you that's
fine but I'm just saying these are the
most common criticisms that I see so
let's try to craft a script that
addresses all these issues and before we
start let's remember it's 1983 folks so
there's no sequels yet no episode 7 and
much in the way of the extended universe
so remember that because yes I will be
borrowing some ideas that showed up
later
what frankly I think they might work
better here so let's get started first
[Music]
second Death Star yeah
Wayne apologist like to say it's larger
but I don't even realize that till force
awakens like there's no sense of scale
if you wanted to make it look bigger why
don't you put it next to a larger moon
who does that
so how do we fix it honestly this is
where I would bring in the star killer
base yeah I actually thought that was a
cool idea in force awakens the only
problem was it was 30 years too late
it's redundant because it's our third
globe-shaped
super weapon but now imagine you're a
kid and you see this in Jedi I'd be like
are you a whole planet that can move
drain of stars energy and blow up other
planets eons away that would be badass
in 1983 he'll presented as the ultimate
project that's been put together in
secret since the Empire's founding the
Death Star itself that was the side
project this is the real deal and how
about this let's kill two birds with one
stone let's make the moon they've been
hollowing out into this super weapon for
decades be Endor now up the ante even
further it's not just a super weapon the
emperor is constructing a new Capitol
he's paving over this planet and turning
it into the new core Assad so it's half
forest half city with a trench being the
dividing line you know for
because clearly they haven't finished
the job yet since it's still under
construction
they'll pave over the bottom half later
they've just been going bit by bit
there's your built-in environmental
message something I actually thought was
clever about Jedi in a tokine vietnam
guerrilla warfare metaphoric a Dawei
this gives the natives plenty of time
and ammunition to mount a
counter-offensive that makes sense
hell I would play at the Emperor's
hubris by having Vader tell Mafia Jim
Jojo that jemima you know what I don't
know how to pronounce his name I'm
calling him JJ so I'd have Vader tell
moth JJ that the regional governors will
be invited to see the first test run of
this thing
this sets up how much the Empire is a
invested in this thing be a freaking
arrogant they are and see just how fast
they can be taken down all in one shot
then maybe I'd follow this up with a
scene on some distant planet rebel
commander maybe wedge gets told by the
legendary boffins that their Intel
indicates the galaxy is ready for a
revolution but there needs to be a spark
a decisive victory
if the rebellion is gonna strike they
need to move fast like what's the holdup
and then maybe wedge lets it slip that
well there's a quote-unquote leadership
issue and this is what takes us to
Jabba's palace
well okay let's be honest this whole job
a bit is like a 40 minute detour whose
only goal was to get Han back otherwise
it's totally pointless Muppets are nice
but it's too long so how do we shorten
it and tie it all together with the rest
of the film first off Leia disguised as
the OBC bounty hunter is the one who
drops the droids off she claims she's
simply delivering these things on behalf
of an unknown client as a fellow bounty
hunter she's allowed to stay despite the
suspicious eye of Bubba Fett maybe then
we can get some palace entertainment or
as Brad Jones likes to call it Caligula
with Muppets she witnesses the death of
Jabba's slave but she can't do anything
about it because it would blow her cover
so that would be a nice dark scene plus
it also sets up the rancor at night she
tries to sneak on out we see Lando
coming down blaster drawn ready for
backup but whoops Leia is caught
FET it turns out tip Java off then the
gomorian guards burst in with Chewie he
put up quite a fight but was overpowered
turns out he was waiting some distance
away by the Falcon so now the plan at
least is clear when diplomacy fails
layout Lando and Chewie would bust Han
out
Lando's still in disguise tells him
through the prison door that their whole
plan went awry but there's a backup Luke
Han is needless to say unimpressed and
still doesn't trust Lando anyway now cut
to Luke he walks in this before and is
frisked he's unarmed while talking with
Jabba Lando sneaks up and slyly removes
Artoo's restraining bolt yes in this
version he actually has a goddamn
restraining bolt Jabba says something
like it's foolish for a boy to come
alone and unarmed to which Luke says
something to the effect of that's the
thing I'm neither there's an explosion
and guards scream that they're under
attack by rebel forces our two shoots
the lightsaber horizontally - Luke Jabba
slams on the trapdoor button and Luke is
left to face the rancor in the chaos
Lando busts Han and Chewie out but
they're chased by Bubba Fett down the
hallways as rebel forces enter the base
r2 Jackson to the computer and opens the
trapdoor Luke force jumps out and slices
away while Leia strangles Java the whole
gang then is gathered in front of
Jabba's corpse when Bubba Fett tries to
take a shot at them all
Luke flings his lightsaber around and it
takes out FETs gun Fett by the way is
pissed the heroes then run from the
palace being chased by Javas guards
unfortunately for them they run into a
rebel army and surrender Luke's x-wing
takes off his white wings bomb Jabba's
palace boom big explosion then the
Falcon takes off across the Tatooine
desert but uh-oh baba phat watches with
silent rage there that should take
twenty minutes tops and the rebels even
managed to take prisoners some of whom
informed their captors that they have
information turns out that the Hutt
crime syndicate hears rumors of a new
imperial super weapon that makes the
Death Star look like a nerf gun han
leads the interrogation himself because
he knows some of Hots goons his report
he believes them there's something big
and it's going to destroy the rebellion
so now this D
- or at least has moved the story along
this brings us to the fallout of all
this
I don't think Han and Lando would be so
buddy-buddy in fact I think Han would be
pissed that Lando the betrayer is now a
general all of a sudden for his part
Landa would be pissed that Han is more
grateful for the rescue in fact I think
Han would want to leave oh yeah
han is skittish why wouldn't he be after
all that in a hallway Leia confronts him
and he lays it on the table
he bet on Lando and it nearly killed him
for the first time in his life he feels
like his luck has run out
how long will hers last how many more
revolutions quests suicide missions
if Jabba's Intel is true then this is
the end game and he has a free ticket
out of here
he's got no bow anymore he's got no
debts and as far as the empire is
concerned he is dead or at least frozen
in carbonite so he makes her an offer
come with me let's disappear into the
galaxy together so now we've come full
circle
he made Luke this offer in a new hope
out of selfishness
he just wanted somebody to help him on
his missions this time he wants to save
Leia the woman he loves
but Leia says he can't do that why
because the rebellion needs me no Han
she says I need you so now we've got a
complete role reversal from back on Hoth
where she denied she needed him
unfortunately their chance to consummate
this confession with a kiss is
interrupted by Threepio
who says mon mothma wishes to meet with
the princess this whole thing just
proves Hans point go he says it's where
you're needed in her office mon mothma
expresses her unease that they've
effectively taken over Tatooine and
there hasn't been an imperial response
leia notes that they might be too busy
planning something that's what worries
me mon mothma says she then presses
layabout solo they wasted a lot of
manpower getting him back was it worth
it
leia claims it is but she knows he's
having second thoughts then a message
beeps from the docking bay captain solo
is requesting leave to do maintenance
runs on the falcon leia seems hesitant
Mothma asks if she should be worried
Leia shakes her head no but still looks
pretty damn worried mon mothma grants
clearance we then have wedge enter with
a bomb
turns out the galaxy is ready for
revolution but the boffins have
uncovered a super weapon confirming the
Hutt's Intel so Mon Mothma orders the
fleet to convene at Sullust and request
the boffins find a data readout of the
station so now we're laying some
groundwork for some drama everyone is
falling apart can they come back
together again
Luke meanwhile goes to Yoda and the only
thing I would change here is that he
hands Luke a special wooden box after
telling him the last of the Jedi are you
will be he instructs Luke to open it
only when his feelings tell him at the
time is right this MacGuffin will last
throughout the whole movie back on the
Falcon shirin forms Han that the fleet
is massing at Sullust Han wonders aloud
what to do he calls back to Episode four
I don't know what you think a princess
and a guy like me Chewie roars huh and
Han says I knew you'd say that
said of course Chewie roars basically
asking where and Han says home this
leads to the surprise reveal during the
battle plant sequence Leia can't find
Han at the meeting and assumes that he's
gone for good
then Mon Mothma calls on general solo to
assemble his team and boom there he is
han steps out from behind a bunch of
guys or a pillar or something and
basically it's like all right we're back
everything's cool again then of course
Luke says count me in and yadda yadda
yadda blah blah blah the only real
difference in the battle strategy from
here on out is that there's a shield
generator on the other side of the
dividing trench this shields the moon
itself since the moon is also the super
weapon it has to be brought down so that
the x-wings can fly into the moon's
interior and blow up the reactor core
Lando wants to take the Falcon but again
Han is hesitant and no han doesn't offer
in this version he still can't bring
himself to fully trust Lando
butthey begrudging Lee agrees since he
knows it's what the Alliance wants so
step by step at least he's slowly
rebuilding some sense of trust back with
him so now we end up on Endor which as
we said before is basically half a
Starkiller base but what about the Ewoks
well when Leia encounters wicket I
wouldn't change a thing
blasphemy I know I know but let me
explain
I treat wicked for what he is a kid so
let him be cute
let there be kids the only change I'd
make I would have Leia decide to follow
wicket even though she should be looking
for HQ so instead of blindly following
the Ewok she's acting on some sort of
intuition when the rest of the gang gets
hauled in that's when the real
difference has become clear I think the
biggest problem with the Ewoks is that
they're too cute except this guy this
guy is awesome
seriously more like this guy let's do a
redesign have the kids look like classic
Ewoks played by legends like Warwick
Davis but make the adults taller little
slimmer may be played by petite gymnast
or dancers or something so that rebels
tall but not wicked short either then
adorn them with more ornate and fearsome
headgear make them more like old-school
Native Americans or ancient Incas or
Aztecs or maybe even Celts give them a
more complex culture when the gang is
released have leia show them around
reveal what she's discovered yeah that's
right leia was doing shit she can show
Han that they're skilled hunters she can
show them crude tapestries and maps that
reveal the Empire has been destroying
their homeland for years if not decades
she can show them how many hundreds of
settlements there are and most
importantly she can show them the number
of traps they've been building oh yes
they've been ready to go to war for a
while and in coincides with the
rebellions clandestine operation in fact
Leia can literally say Han I think these
creatures are going to war
of course this leads to an immediate
argument because Han knows this whole
moon is going to be going up in smoke
while Leia insists coming from Alderaan
after all that to do this would make
them no better than the Empire Luke
sides with Leia insisting that there's
always another way this is the theme of
the movie and now it's being played out
in every plot thread of course Han sees
of his Leia still having feelings for
Luke remember that love triangle has not
been resolved yet so we storms Oh
then maybe he watches Chewie training
some of the kids with his crossbow maybe
a rebel officer notes how Chewie seems
to have found some new friends and Han
reminds himself out loud that Chuy's
family and planet was enslaved by the
Empire so there's a kinship there that's
when he realizes he has to try another
way so Han Van shoves the battle plans
into r2 and tells Threepio if you don't
want your worshippers blown to
smithereens and you'd better figure out
something and fast the result
they'll disable the Corps using the
x-wings but there's a problem with this
it means it's gonna be a much more
costly ground battle hun reports this to
Mon Mothma she asked if it will work
clearly worried and Han replies with a
typical Harrison Ford bravado we'll make
it work and so Mon Mothma puts her faith
in solo meanwhile Luke asks Leia how she
knew how to follow these creatures
instead of finding base camp she
confesses it was like an inner voice
told her to do so it's then that Luke
realizes he needs to come clean with her
about her force powers so he confesses
the whole sibling thing and leaves her
with the box that Yoda gave him to only
be open should he not return if I don't
come back you're the only hope for the
rebellion
[Music]
the Battle of Endor starts off the same
drop the only difference is it's an
entire front that the Ewoks have opened
up against the trench dividing the
planet forcing moth JJ to scatter his
forces pretty much everywhere meanwhile
at the Imperial Palace still under
construction
the Emperor reveals that it was he who
allowed the rebellion to know about the
base and he adds who do you think it was
who told the Syndicates about our plan
then boom oh shit
it's Boba Fett he steps out from behind
a pillar the Emperor gives him leave to
lay waste to Solo and his friends on the
cinterion moon Luke raises his saber to
stop him Shh but Vader blocks him with
his own sword thus beginning that fight
on the ground the Ewoks used their traps
which have now been fully set up within
the plot unfortunately the Empire sends
out tie bombers this leads Lando to make
a bold move in the middle of the space
battle he calls on two x-wing pilots to
join him in hyper spacing through the
shield another fun idea that I thought
force awakens kind of got right it's
super risky but Akbar agrees on the
ground han and Leia are pinned by the
shield door entrance then Lando when the
Falcon busts in and provides air support
he lands next to han and Leia but before
they can relax an unidentified ship
takes out the 2x wings it's slave 1 oh
shit Boba Fett on orders Leia to assume
command
he and Landa will draw Fett away Leia
resists but Han tells her it's time to
step up to the plate otherwise they're
all dead she assumes command and orders
her squad to guard the door while r2
tries to punch through han and Lando
dogfight with Boba Fett above the forest
of Endor and we finally get an ending
worthy of FETs called status I'd have
the Falcon crash next to the trench feta
the windows out of the cockpit and then
Lando and Han rushing out to face him
two on one Lando winds up dangling over
a cliff fetch shoots Hans blaster from
his hands and then Han leaves in the
Falcon the Celestion presumably flying
it off fat then gloats to Lando that he
should have chosen his friends better
aims his blaster but look out the Falcon
rises from the trench in front of Bubba
Fett han is at the cannons there's a
pause han says something cool like
here's your bounty and then Hans eats
first
FET goes out in a blaze of laser glory
and falls into the abyss Lando is
understandably pissed like man he could
have killed me and Han shoots back with
something like and you call yourself a
gambling man and there it is finally now
they're cool tension resolved trust
earned everything's fine I'm fine you're
fine we're all fine here thank you how
are you
but Leia trams in via communicator they
still can't get through the shield or
Chewie shows up in the chicken Walker he
commandeered with the Ewoks yeah I kind
of like that scene in the original
I'd keep it Han then orders him to help
lay his squad and calls on Leia to
dispatch r2
why she asks even looks at slave 1
parked right next to the Falcon I have
an idea we next see Han asking r2 if he
can really fly slave 1 meanwhile
Threepio is pitching a fit but the plan
is set and r2 auto pilots the ship's
straight for the shield or at the last
second r2 a Jets with it slave 1 in its
entire set of proton torpedoes goes up
in smoke the door is now just a
festering hole and the rebels and Ewoks
can pour in across the bridge over the
trench eventually they take out the
shield just like in the original movie
and wedge can begin his attack run
meanwhile it's business as usual on the
throne room fader saves Luke Emperor
gets tossed blah blah blah you get it
right before the Emperor's fall the
rebels and Ewoks push further into the
imperial city and find me off JJ
they try to force him to surrender but
there's a sudden noise the whole moon
starts to shake and alarm sounds what
does that mean leia asks moth JJ replies
it means the emperor's dead a giant beam
rings out from the moon and every
capital ship above Endor starts listing
we then cut to Luke dragging Vader he
collapses in despair and explains that
the Emperor Driggs the reactor to
explode in the event of his death it's
in full meltdown mode it's creating a
gravity well that prevents hyperspace it
can't be disabled by the x-wings and it
can't be destroyed except by exploding
by saving his son Anakin is now doomed
them all the entire moon and with it the
entire Imperial and rebel fleet will go
out in a fiery blaze there's no time for
anyone to escape the shockwave
and here is where we get the sacrifice
Vader begs Luke to do what he could not
save your sister save your friends but
what about you Luke says I came to save
you
you already have and then he dies
back at the imperial barracks moth JJ
orders his men to surrender and
basically face their fate for the glory
of the Empire
he then turns to Leia if there are any
you hold dear I would seek them out in
your final moments Leia insists on
finding Luke han calls on the bus a top
Falcon and they race to the Imperial
Palace as they race there Luke uses the
force to tell Leia that he's going to
eject the core Leia tells the others in
a panic
adding he'll kill himself Leia presses
Han to go faster towards the palace for
the first time Luke communicates with
Han through the forest telling him you
know what you have to do han turns the
ship around as Leia screams at him to go
back han silently refuses through the
forest Leia tells Luke that the core is
too powerful too big even for a Jedi to
handle Luke stands in front of the
emperor's throne and force shoves it out
of the way he then walks up to the
window and extends his hands he summons
the words of Master Yoda size matters
not as wedge in his squadron fly circles
around the core trying to disable it
Luke sends out a final message wedge get
out of there
there's nothing more you can do wedge
orders all the fighters to pull out just
then the reactor core starts to move in
the throne room Luke is using all of his
force mite sweating and convulsing as
the moon itself quakes we see wedges
x-wing last in line fighting to beat the
reactor core out of the shaft at the
same time the Falcon screams away from
the fissure that's opened up near the
shaft at the last second wedge makes it
out behind the Falcon the earth erupts
and the core just barely misses it from
the throne room window Luke watches and
presses on launching the core in front
of him into the darkness of space it
cuts through the executor killing
Admiral Piett and the regional governors
Luke pushes it further still and that
disappears near the Centurion star
finally it explodes in a giant flash
Luke collapse as much as he did at the
end of last Jedi exhausted he takes his
last breath as the forest theme plays
very briefly the explosion creates a
second star reminiscent of the duel son
tatooine the star slowly fades out of
the universe and so Luke Skywalker fades
away too
leaving only as Jedi uniform the falcon
lands in the woods and the heroes step
out the Ewoks celebrate his lay it
watches the second star disappear on
says he's sure Luke made it out alright
but she knows he's gone hun uses the
past tense you loved him yeah
this time the sibling reveal is done for
drama not goofy comedic effect later Mon
Mothma personally congratulate them for
doing the galaxy a great service it's
then that the rebel officers inform Leia
that Lord Vader's body has been found
but there's no sign of Luke Skywalker
except for this she's handed luke's jedi
uniform and robotic hand that night it's
leia
who sets Vader's body luke's mechanical
hand in his uniform ablaze then we cut
to the party we all remember everyone is
celebrating and even leia seems happy
but she withdraws for a moment alone she
stands on the bridge where Luke told her
he was leaving to confront Vader there
she carefully opens the box that Luke
gave her but queeth to him by Master
Yoda the force music plays and her eyes
opened wide and shocked
it's a lightsaber she extends her arm
and instinctively turns it up then
something catches her eye the force
ghosts of Luke Anakin
obi-wan and Yoda are staring back at her
she smiles and cries tears of joy Han
approaches behind her in shock but then
nods knowingly at Luke Lando then
approaches along with three P&R two who
are beside themselves the final shot
shows every generation living in dead
Leia Sabre extended flanked by Han Lando
and the droids and Luke flanked by
Anakin obi-wan and Yoda in the middle x
wings fly and fireworks explode the
music crescendos
and there it is hopefully I've shown how
some script changes can make for a more
fulfilling trilogy one that keeps the
third film a little more in line with
Empire the Java scenes now tie into the
whole plot it's where the rebels first
Intel comes from and they're also
tighter and make more sense
failing diplomacy Leia Chewie and Lando
try and escape failing that Luke in the
rebellion or the contingency plan some
might point out that the Hutt's are
super powerful but this was a lazy
apologists excuse after the fact there's
no reason that the rebellion shouldn't
be able to take out the huts in the
world that the 1983 version provided
Bubba Fett furthers the plot planting
rumors about the new super weapon and he
goes out in a blaze of glory befitting
his character han goes from being a
broken man riddled with PTSD convinced
that his luck has run out to a competent
military commander who steps up to the
plate his arguments with Leia actually
find a better more humanitarian solution
and his faith in Leia forces her to step
up as the rebellions last hope
allowing han and Lando to take on Bubba
Fett the Ewoks now have an actual
culture Endor slash Starkiller base is a
metaphor for nature versus technology
and the Ewok attack now makes more sense
they've been preparing for this for
months
finally Luke's sacrifice gives the
trilogy a much-needed sense of meaning
this might seem depressing to some but
here's a kid the whole idea of force
ghosts made death seem much less harsh
kids can grasp a character sacrificing
himself and living on in a spiritual
sense way better than adults like Lucas
realize yeah it's a rough ride but the
heroes end their journey on a happy note
celebrating their victory and knowing
that Luke is around as a ghostly
spiritual mentor and that solves the
last problem Jedi makes much about how
Leia is the only hope for the rebellion
but in the original she gets shot in the
shoulder and then yeah that's it this is
bang ouch okay so now the torch has
passed the whole original plot actually
makes sense now but for the few the
proud who are all like I offered this
out
and if you're a fan of this character
you may not like it but kill them off
that's right
kill Mon Mothma yeah she has to go maybe
she pulls a whole dough
maybe her cruiser goes down but the
result is loop lives and Leia becomes
the new leader of the rebellion so take
your pick with either of those endings
but that's the biggest problem with Jedi
the Luke side of the story is perfect
wouldn't change a thing
but everyone else becomes a caricature
for it for all the great stuff happening
in the Emperor's throne room the rest
Java Han Leia Boba Fett the Ewoks
they're all just kind of a tease a bunch
of ideas without a lot of payoff
Luke's whole theme is there's always
another way and well maybe this is
another option
perhaps you agree with me perhaps you
don't let me know and post your own
ideas in the comments the Star Wars
universe encompasses decades now of
myths and legends so try not to get to
up in arms about this after all this is
about one of the legends that the people
might speak of in a galaxy far far away
[Music]
you